what america was doing at the un was um
they got back into the u.n human rights
council you know and now they're sitting
on that human rights council shoulder
shoulder with russia and china who um
russia is now committing war crimes so
by neither needs to to kick russia out
of the human rights council or he needs
to get off himself
america was active at the u.n in in
dealing with this iran deal can you
imagine now that you're going to go in a
room and negotiate with china and russia
on you know how to stop iran from
producing nuclear weapons that's that's
a joke
so if you were still the ambassador at
the un right now if you were the u.s
ambassador at the un and you were
sitting apart from sitting across the
table from your russian counterpart
right now what would you be saying to
him
like how do we get putin to turn back
like what what do you think his off-ramp
is what would you be offering them to
say hey okay this thing got messy for
two weeks but let's let's back up now
well first of all dave i would be
railing at the united nations right now
i would have been railing every single
day
um to get some attention towards ukraine
before this conflict happened but also
to kind of rally the world into not just
saying you're with ukraine but actually
doing something about it and having them
act and the first group that needs to
act in the europeans it's their region
they need to really step up did we do
anything did we do anything at the u.n i
mean this was like a slow motion war for
three weeks where biden kept saying oh
it's going to happen maybe it'll happen
tomorrow three days i mean were we doing
anything at the u.n oh yes absolutely um
what america was doing at the un was um
they got back into the u.n human rights
council you know and now they're sitting
on that human rights council shoulder
shoulder with russia and china who um
russia is now committing war crimes so
by neither needs to to kick russia out
of the human rights council or he needs
to get off himself
america was active at the u.n in in
dealing with this iran deal can you
imagine now that you're going to go in a
room and negotiate with china and russia
on you know how to stop iran from
producing nuclear weapons that's that's
a joke and it would it's a fireable
offense if biden continues to try and
get into this iran deal and so yeah they
were doing things they were doing all
the wrong things and what they should
have been doing was rallying the troops
what they should have been doing was
tough love to the europeans saying stop
this and you know one of the things i
did was i was constantly beating up
germany for nordstrom 2 and you know and
we were constantly saying this can't
happen that never should have been
allowed to happen um this year so there
were a lot of things done it just were
all the wrong things
so when
they have a resolution at the u.n and
one of the countries that's doing the
invading has veto power is it all just
theater i mean at the end like is it
just sort of ridiculous theater because
russia vetoed the resolution about
russia you can't blame them for doing
that so the interesting thing is yes
russia vetoed the resolution in the
security council um but what they were
able to do that russia couldn't do
anything about was they took it to the
general assembly you know the 193
countries and what happened was you know
basically the world condemned russia
there were only five countries on the
side of russia russia included but
russia stood there with syria and north
korea those are not friends you want to
be sitting on the corner with and that's
who they were and so yeah they did that
but at the end of the day what does a
resolution do right so
yes it's you know you're you're
condemning you're telling russia you're
bad you got to stop but it's not doing
anything and so you know there goes to
my um frustration with the united
nations is you know saying something and
acting that's great now what you know
now we got it
so so what does a a sane resolution of
this situation look like to you i mean
is this something that we're just going
to be sort of slowly in for a long time
is there something that we can do to
give putin that off ramp so that he
doesn't have to escalate what what is a
what does an actual out of this look
like well i think look at the
environment right so you've got
ukrainians um taking to the streets to
defend themselves you've got russians
it's pretty ironic that you've got
thousands of russians taking to the
streets of russia protesting putin
extremely courageous because they know
that they'll be killed they know that
they'll be jailed for doing that
you've got you know the europeans really
stepping up at a time to help ukraine i
think that you're going to see russia is
going to continue to take
uh ukraine by force um i think they're
going to kind of sit on the barrier for
a while um and try and see how much
progress they can make but at the end of
the day
putin's going to try and put one of his
own lackeys in government um you know in
ukraine but the ukrainian people aren't
going to go for that i mean i think
you've seen the spirit of the ukrainian
people they're not ever going to go for
that so putin's got to figure this out
you know he's already become a pariah in
the world he's isolating himself so he's
already very paranoid um i think he's
worried about being eliminated himself
we know that he's trying to eliminate
zielinski um so you know i think this
isn't going to
be done in a couple of days the sad part
is the media is going to get tired of
raised the media is not going to have
constant ukraine shots and everybody
else is going to go back to their
business but the bloodshed's not going
to stop and i think this is going to
last a while
yeah i'm glad you mentioned the media
part of this because i feel that it's my
job to just sort of translate some of
this stuff to my audience and bring on
people like you who are the experts in
this so that they can get an honest
assessment of this one of the things
that i'm really struggling with right
now is who to trust you know i've lost
such trust in our corporate press that
you know it's very hard for me to pick
up the new york times that i feel lies
about so many things and say oh but this
is the thing they're telling the truth
on how do you i mean is it just from
talking to other ambassadors and talking
to people on the ground how do you get
news that makes sense to you i read a
lot and i read a lot of different
sources and i do i have been in
conversations with my um
counterpart at the united nations from
ukraine who's now back in ukraine um you
know we we're talking to people who have
families on the ground in russia you
know you just you read as much as you
can and you take all the opinions out of
it that's the key is you know the media
wants to tell you what to think you
don't need to know what to think you
need to know the facts and then you put
together what you think on your own and
so
you know you can't read too much but the
media at this point i will say the media
at least they're covering ukraine in
what is a fair way they're not trying to
you know rosie up on on putin they're
they're calling him the thug that he is
they're showing the bloodshed that's
happening they're they're highlighting
zielinski and the brave um people of
ukraine and i think that's what we need
to see but you know the media hasn't
been
an outlet to trust for a very long time
do you think that if it was the guy that
you worked for president trump and this
was happening right now that the media
would be treating this the same i mean
it seems fairly obvious to me that the
media would be everything would be at
the footsteps of america right now and
this is what trump brought upon us i
mean you can actually see them doing
some of that blaming trump for this sake
you know you probably saw that line the
other day where she said there's a
pattern here of uh of putin invading
ukraine she forgot that the thing that
broke the pattern was the four years
under trump
you know it's interesting because i've
i've always told everybody you know the
four years that president trump had he
never got an ounce of peace or
one bit of credit through all four years
he was hammered every day all day and he
didn't have afghanistan he didn't have
the ukraine mess he didn't have
inflation like this he didn't have the
crime in the streets he didn't have all
that and they still beat up on them and
then you know to go have them hail by
the state of the union speech um as this
amazing unifier you know it wasn't that
all it was was a lot of republican
talking points saying you know we've got
to get rid of crime on the streets we've
got to put kids back in school we have
to choose freedom over tyranny you know
we've got to fund the police well guess
what we've been saying that this entire
year that biden's been in office and now
he's saying it but you he didn't offer
one solution not one solution and you
know the only solution dave is to win
the races in 2022 we've got to take back
the house we've got to take back the
senate we've got 36 governor's races and
if you ever saw um the the importance of
a governor you know you saw it during
covet and you saw some fantastic
republican governors go and protect
their people and i think that we've got
to really make sure that we put a stop
to all of this progressive
extremism that we're seeing come out of
the left and you know stop biden and try
and you know say a prayer along the way
because it's going to be a long three
years if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell